I'm here on the streets of Hollywood
to find out the answer to one special question
I'm just trying to figure something out
I'm just wondering if you could tell me the answer to one question
Aight, what's up?
Do you know if women poop?
I don't think so.
No I've never seen it happen.
No.
Women don't poop?
No, of course not.
I think it's one of those mysteries that can never be solved.
An unsolved mystery
An unsolved mystery. Like I could ask you right now
Do you poop? And you could give me one of two answers, what would yours be?
Yes
Okay, so there you go. But that's just one person.
But here's what's confusing, right?
Like, I know that I take shits.
But then everyone's like women don't poop, and I'm like where is this disconnect happening?
You never know.
Why do you think people are going around saying women don't poop?
Because people probably think that, like, it's gross for women to poop.
People don't like to see women in like...
Not necessarily dirty, but like...
I'm not sure, I don't know how to put it.
They think it's unladylike
We're supposed to be ladylike
It's not ladylike
What about it is unladylike?
Being a human?
Yeah, women aren't human.
Where do you think that originates from?
Uh, fear.
misogyny
Big time.
Definitely that.
I think that the solution, that you speak of, should be smashed.
I think that we should all be proud of that.
Oh what?
Of pooping.
I poop.
You poop?
Yes, we do.
Women do poop.
We all poop. We have to.
Everybody poops.